good morning John as you can see I still
have this annoying clingy face for
attached to my body and people are
starting to tell me that I look like
Wesley The Princess Bride and I'm
starting to feel like that's not so bad
I feel like I look like a cat though
that's that fuzzy faces and pokes me
constantly poked me I don't even know
how I handle the hair on my head anymore
but due to an overwhelming influx of
comments about how much people like my
goatee and how much they don't want me
to shave it I've kept it for now and if
you're wondering how I got this
excellent sort of shape to it it's
because hair does not grow here it's
just me being a little boy John this is
gonna sound like a weird topic change
but have you ever heard of physiognomies
I learned about physiognomies while
searching the website of Kim McGuire who
played hatchet face and crybaby who I'm
kind of obsessed with also in that
Wikipedia page I found out that John
Waters cast the part of hatchet face
with one line and wanted girl with a
good body and an alarming face who was
proud of it anyway physiognomies is the
assessment of a person's character by
looking at their face or Bob this is on
its face that was intention it wasn't it
yes yeah it was intentional but I wasn't
gonna call attention to it anyway that
is on its face wrong we shouldn't judge
people by what they look like we all
know that except in some cases you kind
of can for example aggressive men tend
to have wider faces because they have
more testosterone in their system when
they were growing gay men our three
notes were unlikely to have
counterclockwise hair whirls and that's
just weird
I checked I had Catherine check my nan
clockwise so now we know for sure and a
composite of thousands of religious
women were put together 73% of people
identified that image as a composite of
a religious person but these are all
just little tips they're not something
we actually take into account right well
whether or not we should judge a book by
its cover
we do man with faces that more closely
resemble children are less likely to be
convicted in a court of law than men who
look more masculine and yet maybe face
men are more likely to be convicted of
negligence psychologists have studied
this and they've determined that within
1/10 of a second of seeing a person for
the first time we have already made a
series of judgments not just about how
attractive they are but how trustworthy
they are how assertive they are how
funny they're going to be we're built to
make these snap judgments about each
other because at some point in our
history it was necessary for our
survival to do so and now we build even
more signals into the way we
style our hair the shoes that we wear
the socks the clothes tattoos and
piercing all a way to give cultural cues
about what kind of person we are all of
this brings me back to the coat does
this thing change who I am does it
change the way people see me and if
people see me differently do I see
myself differently
do I act differently because that's the
way that they see me not so far I think
do I seem different I don't know if I
had stuck with contacts in high school
and looked like this all the time would
I have been a different person is this
guy not me when it comes down to is this
is too big of a decision for me to make
alone and it's also too good of an
opportunity to raise money for the
foundation to decrease worldsuck
we need to increase the coffers now in
preparation for the project for awesome
so if you have an opinion on whether or
not I should keep this face fuzz intact
or not go to Fite worldsuck org right
and you can vote but not with your
clicks with your dollars I will tell you
that PayPal takes like 33 cents no
matter what so if you donate a dollar 33
cents of that going to PayPal if you
donate 5 33 cents that that's going to
PayPal so percentage-wise
you should probably avoid just doing a
dollar and if you do less than 33 cents
they take all of it
so that's great so put your money in the
shave it pile or put your money in the
keep it pile and based on that on my
next video I will let you know whether
or not I'm going to do the Neanderthal
November thing John one final note
congratulations on signing a hundred and
fifty thousand copies of The Fault in
Our Stars are done go on vacation except
don't cuz we need you to make videos to
make us laugh I'll see you on Monday